STUDENT: My question is in regards to mainline
Protestantism here in the states, and the four
factors
you have laid out.
Arguably, you know, the Episcopal Church, for
instance, meets-- has met a number of
those factors, and increasingly so
as it's declined.
So how do you account for that?
GORSKI: Oh, I got a very simple answer for this.
Demography.
There's a
wide, wide--
widely shared misunderstanding which is systematically
propagated by--
by certain
religious
movements within the United States-- Evangelicals--
that
the growth of Evangelicalism has to do with
the-- relative to the mainline Protestantism-- has to
do with the success of their
outreach or the character of their theology.
Basically, it's all about
average levels of female fertility.
Even--
have, you know, on average-- Evangelical women,
for example, on average have, you know, 3.4,
3.5
children during their lifetimes, whereas mainline
Protestants,
you know, are well below replacement levels--
1.4,
in more liberal Protestant congregations. Obviously, you know,
to the degree to which religious reproduction
is partly about biological reproduction is
about that, to a large degree.
People switch, but not as much as you might
think,
over their lifetimes. They typically switch within--
within denominational families. The decline
in mainline Protestantism
is almost all about declining levels
of female fertility. Now,
that rate-- that points you to what the real
theological question is, which is, you know,
why do--
why do Evangelicals have more kids?
And I don't have a--
you know, I don't have a great answer to that question,
but if you--
you know, if you come up with one,
I guarantee you, you'll get a lot of attention.
VOLF: How about the Episcopalians-- how are the Episcopalians
having this gaping hole-- I'm one-- but we've got
gaping hole between 12 and
in our congregations. So it's not just the
low rates of fertility-- it's-- it's
lower rates of attraction of
those who you give birth to, right?
So-- which is-- which is a sense of
issue of
the issue of both
internal transmission
and ability to internally transmit,
also. Philip, do you think that way at all?
GORSKI: You know, I--
you know, I haven't really looked at the numbers
really closely. I mean, one thing
I can say is that,
you know, what you're describing is a fairly
typical
phenomenon--
you know, that
in mid-to-late adolescence, people leave.
When they get married and then when they have
kids,
they tend to return.
So, I mean, that's a-- that's a very common-- that's a
very common thing.
What might be true is that,
you know, that--
the kind of--
stricter churches, you know, Evangelical or Pentecostal--
stricter churches, which really have much
stronger for, you know, for theological
reasons, have-- find much stronger forms
of
collective pressure on individuals to remain within
the fold,
may actually do a better job. That's why I say
I don't know the numbers, whether they do
a better job of actually keeping people
active, you know, between the ages of, you know,
whatever, 15 and 18 or
35 or 40. It may may well be that
they do, but, you know, whether that matters
or not a lot in the long run,
again, is a--
that's another question. Maybe it does. Maybe
it does in the sense that-- it could be that's
part of the answer to the fertility problem, that those are--
that that's precisely the period of late adolescence
and young adulthood when people develop certain
kinds of longstanding attitudes towards sexuality,
marriage,
reproduction, and so on.
That's just a
thought, I don't know if it's true.
STUDENT: Can I push back just a little bit on--
the idea of fertility answering it all-- because
it's my understanding that the kind of cradle
of Protestantism
is fading, also, that that's sort of a corresponding
trend that
or-- so,
it seems to me that there has to be something
else accounting for it
given that they are meeting a number of these
factors--
or is it anticipating something that might then,
now, affect some of these flourishing,
growing religions that they haven't yet faced,
and what's-- what's the x factor?
GORSKI: You know, it's conceivable, but, you know,
again I think that,
you know, I think-- there have been several studies
of this-- one particular quite recently,
within the last three or four years-- that,
you know, really find that almost, an extraordinary
amount of this sort of variation is just
explained by pure demography. I mean, I can give you the site
afterward.
You know, whether or not
that-- that's changing--
I mean somebody, you know--
you'd have to really sort of go and look at
the data to figure out whether that's the case. I--
it's not implausible, what you're saying. It's just a question
of whether it's true.